rencontre avec un couple qui a fait de
sa passion un métier david et sandrine
sont vendeurs de pièces détachées légaux
il on possède un million huit cent mille
dans leur entreprise de chateaurenaud
une activité de niche mais qui ne
connaît pas la crise et qui ne s'adresse
pas qu'aux enfants aurélie renault est
allé à leur rencontre dans les sous sols
d'une entreprise de chateaurenaud un
trésor 15000 références de petites
pièces plastiques bienvenue chez brick
store toute la journée l'équipe
sillonnent les allées pour préparer des
commandes 1 million 800 mille pièces de
lego sont stockées ici
elles partiront dans toute la france
mais également en europe
ouais on essaie d'être plus de commandes
qu'ils vont de 3 à 4,5 euros se lance
sur le nouveau client qui nous
découvrent qu'ils testent d'abord notre
service et puis ensuite on a des
commandes qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 150
200 300 ça dépend du projet qu'on a
réalisé bien sûr il ya toujours le
second père d'une petite pièce où le
chien qui a grignoté une petite pièce
mais on a une moyenne d'âge de clientèle
45 ans dont se sont rejoints des
passionnés qui ont en plus tôt détourner
le produit pour en faire de la maquette
créé il ya cinq ans le site de vente en
ligne cartonne briques store est ainsi
devenu le plus gros revendeurs en france
avec près de 200 colis envoyés chaque
jour par les sept salariés et
l'entreprise à des projets de
développement dans quelques semaines les
gérants ouvre une boutique de lego à
domicile mais le nouveau bébé des
dirigeants c'est cet espace encore
secret une exposition permanente de lego
sur plus de 150 m² les dirigeants de
briques store n'en dévoile qu'une petite
partie à nos caméras ils veulent garder
l'effet surprise pour l'ouverture par
exemple ici le ce bateau c'est ma femme
qui la montée en suivant la notice et le
plan de la boîte du set légaux tout ce
qui est là d'ailleurs ce qui les a
montées et ensuite mois dont j'ai fait
la conception des vitrines qui sont pas
encore terminés achevé mais la
conception des vitrines et mis en place
et en scène et encore du travail
star wars les châteaux la fête foraine
la gare la caserne des pompiers
l'exposition permanente mettra en scène
25 univers